[Musique]
nicolas sarkozy vraiment le président
qui est capable et qui en mesure de
rassembler tous les français de quitter
origines de toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles et ça c'est très
important
c'est quelqu'un qui est capable de
diriger la france
c'est pas uniquement au niveau d'un
france mais aussi au niveau de l'europe
et ça quelqu'un qui ne te laisse pas
faire c'est quelqu'un qui avance il a en
plus pu acquérir une expérience d'homme
d'état depuis cinq ans je pense que ces
cinq dernières années vont lui bénéficié
pour les cinq prochaines années y a des
qualités qui me plaît chez lui comme la
ténacité la franchise est justement de
réaliser des réformes comme la réforme
des retraites je suis pro nicolas
sarkozy parce qu'il parle juste juste on
ne peut pas lui reprocher entendant la
vanité ça fait pas toujours plaisir mais
ça fait toujours du bien
mes chers compatriotes j'ai choisi
d'entendre d'écouter ce que vous nous
avez dit à nous tous les candidats au
premier tour vous dire la vérité
c'est vous dire que si j'ai voulu la
réforme des retraites c'est parce que la
vie s'allonge et que si nous vivons plus
longtemps nous devront cotiser davantage
j'ai voulu préserver le pouvoir d'achat
des retraités
j'ai voulu qu aucun d'entre vous
retraités ne soient la charge de ces
enfants et grâce à cette réforme
aujourd'hui la france a maintenu le
niveau de ces pensions nous ne sommes
pas obligés de faire comme tant de nos
voisins qui ont baissé le niveau des
pensions
je veux que le travail soit récompensé
je veux qu'à chaque instant celui qui
travaille qui cotisent soit davantage
rémunérés que celui qui ne travaille pas
et qui ne cotisent pas je crois au
travail je crois à la solidarité
je refuse l'assistanat c'est la raison
pour laquelle tous ceux qui bénéficient
avec vos cotisations du rsa devront au
minimum de 17 heures de leur temps par
semaine au service de travail d'intérêt
collectif et seront évalués
régulièrement pour voir s'ils font les
efforts d'insertion et de recherche de
travail vous êtes en droit d'exiger cela
de ceux qui bénéficient de la solidarité
le sim est un choix historique avance à
pas le droit à l'erreur
le 6 mai chaque vote va compter votre
choix
décidera de la direction que retiendra
la france
[Applaudissements]
c'est maintenant c'est ici vive la
république
[Musique]